is eight news
now gas prices as we know averaging five
dollars a gallon across the country are
those high prices affecting the sales of
rvs well jeremy j ford is at desert inn
and boulder highway with the answer
i'm here at johnny walker rv and if
you're thinking about hitting the open
road this summer in a camper like this
will it cost you more money or will it
save you some in the long run
when you're on a fixed income you only
got so much money to enjoy and that's it
with gas prices continuing to skyrocket
rv owner dennis barnett tells me that
shouldn't stop you from traveling this
summer it doesn't matter about the
length you stay because it's the fuel
getting there and getting back but it
does matter on how many places you go
with an rv like this johnny walker
general manager ronnie corwin says sales
are still booming we all kind of
expected it to slow down a little bit
because gas prices and stuff like that
but it really hasn't missed a beat
because people are still saving money
with rv you got your own home just like
everything else right now prices have
gone up so hotels restaurants everything
that you do if you don't have an rv is
going to cost more another reason
ownership now can save you down the road
you get an rv that fits your lifestyle
not your lifestyle to fit the rv that
way you're already comfortable with the
way you live your life
and you enjoy your rv because it's part
of you then jeremy j ford live local now
i